الضم والاستحواذ ومصادره الاراضي ممارسات
اقترنت عبر عقود بسياسات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وعلى مرها كان جوهر هذه
السياسات الاحتفاظ باكبر قدر ممكن من
الاراضي والتخلص من اكبر عدد ممكن من
الفلسطينيين ذريعه دائما الحفاظ على الامن
وحمايه المستوطنات والمستوطنين على حساب
اهل الارض الحقيقيين بهذه الذيعه ظلت
مقاربه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي و هي عادته
لتبرير اي خطوه يقوم بها وهو الذي لم يوفق
بعد من صدمه ضربه موجعه وجهتها له
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عبر عمليه طوفان
الاقصى في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي فخاض
وما زال يخوض حربا على غزه استهدفت
المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه وتدمير كل شيء
ينبض بالحياه وبقدر الضربه يكون الوجع لكن
المستوره من نيات القدم والاستيلاء على
مزيد من الاراضي انكشف مره اخرى عبر تسميه
دوائر ومصادر اعلاميه بمنطقه عازله فقطاع
غزه يوصف بانه اكبر سجن مفتوح في العالم
ممتد على نحو
365 كت مربعا منذ السابع من اكتوبر وضمن
عمل ممنهج دمرت اسرائيل الف المنازل والبن
التحتيه والمصانع والمرافق الاقتصاديه
القريبه من السياج الفاصل بالغارات
والمدفعيه وجرفه الاراضي ولانش شاء منطقه
عازله بعمق يتراوح بين كيلومتر وكيل متر
ونصف تقول يدعوت احرونوت ان اسرائيل تعمل
على ابتلاع نحو 20% على الاقل من اراض غزه
وتطهيرها عرقيا بالكامل على ان يتم
احتلالها حتى بعد انتهاء الحرب واضافت بان
الشريط الحدود الجديد الذي سيمتد الى داخل
اراض غزه قد يشمل مواقع عسكريه جديده
وثكنات دائمه او متغيره وطرقا عسكريه
ووسائل مراقبه محميه وتحصينات ومفهوما
دفاعيا تشغيلي
مختلفا دمرت اسرائيل احياء فلسطينيه
باكملها كما هو الحال في بيت حنون وجباليا
والشجاع وهي خطوه ينفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي
بسرعه نسبيه وكل يوم هذا يعني تدمير مدن
وقرا باكملها قبل ايام كان يخطط لتفخيخ
ونسف مبان شرق المغازي على بعد اقل من
كيلومتر عن السياج ليقتل 21 من ضباطه
وجنوده في استهداف للمق للمبنى وهم فيه
لكن المباني ليست وحدها الهدف فالاستخدام
يطال ايضا الاراضي الزراعيه التي تعد سله
غذاء غزه وتحديدا في المنطقه الشماليه
وتحويلها الى منطقه امنيه مشدده هذه خريطه
نشرها مركز الامم المتحده للاقمار
الصناعيه كشف تضرر نحو 39% من المساحات
الزراعيه في محافظه شمال غزه و
27% في محافظه غزه بين نوفمبر وديسمبر
الماضيات
ويظهر هذا الفيديو بتقنيه تايم لابس كيف
تغير شكل الارض وما عليها من ابنيه واراض
زراعيه وسط وجنوب غزه بفعل العمليه
الاسرائيليه والتحضير لهذه المنطقه
العازله مقرر الامم المتحده المعني
بالاسكان وصف ما تقوم به اسرائيل بانه
اعمال تطهير للاملاك على طول الحدود في
قطاع غزه وتدمير منهجي للمنازل الفلسطينيه
يمكن ان يشكل جريمه حرب اما صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز فنقلت عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين ان
الهدف من المنطقه العازله ان تصعب تكرار
هجوم مشابه لهجمات السابع من اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي حينما انهار السياج الحدودي
والتكنولوجيا التي انجزته امام هجمات
المقاومه وا وا واو تبدو المعضله في توفير
ما تقول اسرائيل انه امن للبلدات
الاستراتيجيه على حدود غزه وكثير منها
مستوطنات ومواقع عسكريه وتشجيع لعوده
سكانها الى منازلهم بخلق واقع جديد في نحو
58 بلده تشكل غلاف غزه لكن تقديرات
وتحليلات اسرائيليه تجمع على ان اي خطه
لاقامه منطقه امنيه عازله في قطاع غزه غير
مجديه ولن توفر الامن بل ستغرق تل ابيب في
مستنقع قتال مستدلين بتجربتها في لبنان
حينما اخلت منطقه بعمق 15 كيلومترا عام
2000 بعد سنوات من الهجمات التي شنها حزب
الله الولايات المتحده وعلى لسان وزير
خارجيتها انطوني بلينكن اكدت رفضها لاي
خطه اسرائيليه لانشاء منطقه عازله في قطاع
غزه او اي تغيير دائم للوضع الجغرافي فيها
واعتبرت انها انتهاك للقانون الدولي اسيجه
ومقاربات امنيه ظلت ترافق المستوى السياسي
والعسكري في اسرائيل في تعامله مع ما حدث
في السابع من اكتوبر اكثر من 100 وع ايام
من الحرب لم تحقق فيها اسرائيل اهدافها
التي اعلنتها وحتى على الارض بقدر ما تقدم
جيشها وتوغل الا انه لم يسيطر فاسرائيل
التي تعودت على نهج سياسه الارض المحروقه
ومصادره الارض لم تتمكن من مصادره اراده
اصحاب
الارض